I want to talk about the greatest acting
performance of all time and it's in one
scene and I can't believe I've never
talked about this before but it is I
should have looked it up I just pulled
lieutenant Liu really there's no eating
there
oh so li eu1 fire when he does the
[ __ ] Nicolas Cage when he goes sup
sup you know that scene oh my god dude
I'm looking this up Nicolas Cage sup
dude he keep saying sup in this I'm just
gonna play this is what I'd say I get an
argument all the time with my girl about
this [ __ ] Nicolas Cage greatest actor
of all time
alright you know why he makes choices he
makes he takes chances they're not all
gonna be good but because he does that
it makes him [ __ ] amazing
alright Nicolas Cage is an amazing actor
that has done some bad movies but if I
but this is the he keeps coming out with
movies and I'm like alright so he's the
greatest to take a chance and do this in
a movie is the most donkey balled choice
you could possibly make he's got soman
his balls are so large that he just
sometimes relaxes by sitting on him okay
they're like one of those [ __ ] things
that you can find in the toy stores that
you bounce on those were what his balls
are because of this
so he's in a car with three black guys
now it's important that he's white and
they're black because you can tell
Nicolas Cage God he's so good look at
his face just look at his goddamn face
in this [ __ ] thing he wants to
impress them and this is just unreal
unreal that he does this do it that's
money yeah where's the 15 thousand he
just by saying hey hey stop dude you
don't get it man relax did I not do what
I said I was going to do
yo man relax
tell me again to relax
I'm not looking to beat you man
where's my money let's hold the gun on
him I'll get you money when tomorrow
we're so good my place
give me a cut of the uncut dope so I'm
gonna pay you in money so good this is
interest it's [ __ ]
what's that little man no miss Sheila
yeah fix the coke now put that gun away
before you kill somebody
what's the gun away kill all you and
then
this wasn't there's no way this was in
the script to the break it down amazing
dude how he goes to the breaker dome
maybe so insecure but also so secure bro
Nicolas Cage I'll suck you off straight
up then it goes into the [ __ ] bar to
the [ __ ] to this white guy and and
this is what he does you don't pay your
debts I don't want to know you I can't
afford it
ten grand bye-bye oh yeah five of
Louisiana right there
Oh putting money in his pockets and sup
where'd you get this what are you my
priest six point spread oh [ __ ] he's the
best actor there a beam dude if you
don't think Nicolas Cage is the there's
a comment Nicolas Cage caged the [ __ ]
out of this role I love this man when he
says to the break of dawn baby God he's
[ __ ] full throttle huh Nicolas Cage
is just so good I want to meet him so
bad that's the only guy I'd probably
geek out harder than when I met Keanu
Reeves I don't know that's up there the
two of them are the best different
different Nicolas Cage I genuinely
thinks one of grace after all time
counter is I think is one of the
greatest movie stars but yeah man Wow
just [ __ ] sup sup hey I'm jealous he
did that now I can't do it I gotta get
more of these [ __ ] movies so I could
take [ __ ] donkey ball chances man I
need to take these donkey ball chances
man just gotta get coffee